bonsoir messieurs merci d'être avec nous
ce soir sur rtl france est ce qu'un
gouvernement a raison jean paul stahl de
choisir le past vaccinale plutôt que
d'imposer plus simplement la vaccination
pour olivier ferrand ce serait plus
efficace plus efficace que des amendes
oui bon je pense que le pass à l'itc a
conduit l'obligation à si on veut vivre
à peu près normalement il faut avoir se
classent invités à être vaccinés
correctement ce qui est tout à fait
logique est tout à fait normal pour
obtenir une obligation vaccinale c'est
un petit peu plus compliqué un peu plus
long et là on est dans l'urgence on est
vraiment dans l'urgente aspect ya des
morts qui sont en jeu donc vraiment je
crois que c'est une solution tout à fait
tout à fait correct éviter la punition
collective alors que seuls 5 millions de
français ne sont pas vaccinés ce que
vous entendez cet argument du
gouvernement nicolas les airs
alors pas entièrement pour la bonne et
simple raison que le gouvernement ne
fait pas ce qu'il faut depuis bientôt
deux ans qu'il ya toujours des
contaminations en hausse notamment
concernant milieu scolaire plus de 2200
élèves de primaire étaient contaminés
aurait drôme il ya une semaine enfin le
taux d'incidence pardon était de 1200
700 en collège inn il en primaire
on a affaire à une énorme vague rien et
c'est toujours à 31 par salle donc je
pense pas que ce soit le vaccin
fonctionne particulièrement des eaux on
a plus de contaminations qu'on en a
jamais eu dans le pays alors qu'on est
76 % dont moi être vaccinés
les médecins ne savent plus quoi il
parle je pense qu'ils sont complètement
perdus et au lieu d'avoir l'humilité de
le reconnaître tout comme le
gouvernement on impose des restrictions
qui sont en dehors des réalités en
dehors de ce qui se passe et qui ne
protège pas nos sauf pas sinon on
n'aurait pas des gens vaccinés l'hôpital
sinon n'auraient pas des gens vaccinés
en réa on n'aurait pas des jours
vaccinés qui meurt certes les non
vaccinés sont pleurer père à l'hôpital
enfin il reste un énorme problème c'est
que nous vacciner sont concernés aussi
moi ça m'inquiète entendent personnes
vaccinées j'ai plus qu est ce qui
m'avait été dit par des médecins j'ai
répété ce qui m'avait été dit par le
pouvoir politique
résultat on explique que je peux
toujours contaminé les gens autour de
moi nous élèves nous contamine contamine
nos familles on est toujours trône par
classe je le répète rien n'a été décidé
alors que plein de pays prévoit
d'augmenter afin de prolonger les
vacances pour protéger la population et
en france on ne fait rien comme si on
avait des solutions miracles comme si on
protège et mieux et plus alors on fait
pire qu'ailleurs qu'est ce que vous
répondez à tout ce que vous venez
d'entendre jean paul stahl on ne fait
rien en france pour empêcher cette
propagation du collège
c'est absurde
c'est totalement avions
la vaccination a sauvé des centaines de
milliers de personnes
donc on peut on peut pas dire ça on peut
pas dire ça prendre le prétexte des
enfants et est complètement fou les
enfants sont effectivement des porteurs
c'est vrai mais ils ne sont pas de sujet
à des formes graves
ces deux les formes graves chez les
enfants sont totalement exceptionnel
donc on prend des mesures chez les
enfants et on prend prétexte des enfants
pour finalement excusé nous laisser
tranquilles les personnes qui refusent
la vaccination
la vraie question c'est vacciner les
adultes 6 e qui vont à l'hôpital c'est
eux qui vont en réanimation c'est eux
qui meurt et en ce qui concerne les
vaccinés qui sont en réanimation fut
désolé c'est faux j'ai encore là hier un
tour de un tour d'horizon avec mes
collègues hospitaliers partout en france
ak plus de 90% les personnes qui sont
hospitalisées est en réanimation sont
des personnes non vaccinées ou mal
vaccinés c'est extrêmement simple c'est
factuel le vaccin marche ne pas être
vaccinés c'est courir un risque et c'est
susciter toutes les les inconvénients
que nous sommes amenés à subir
maintenant de façon collective donc là
je refuse totalement ses arguments
nicolau
tout à fait ravis que 40 ans d'exercice
de la médecine ne conduise à cette
appréciation sur l'errance médicale je
suis désolé mais ça fait 40 ans que je
suis infectiologues je prétend connaître
mon sujet olivier ferrand a déclaré que
la vaccination de tous les enfants âgés
de 5 à 11 ans se ferait serait offerte
dès mercredi si tout va bien elle ne
sera donc pas obligatoire quel regard
est ce que vous portez sur cette mesure
nicolas d'hier mais pour le coup
justement je ne suis pas médecin je
regarde un petit peu comme tous les
citoyens comme tous les habitants du
pays la situation se dégrader depuis
deux ans la situation ne pas fonctionner
sur la vaccination des enfants
mangeaient pas d'avis particulier ce que
je peux dire en revanche c'est qu'on
sait que la vaccination n'empêche pas de
contaminer les enfants aux principes ne
sont pas en danger par le cos vite je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec vous là
dessus cela dit c'est un mauvais
argument utilisé par font depuis deux
ans puisqu'ils peuvent contaminer les
autres donc il serait peut être temps de
s'occuper des gens qui contamine les
familles les profs les personnels
d'éducation les clsh qui sont collés à
eux je rappelle quand même que l'an
dernier moi j'aimerais on rappelle les
gens chroniqueur éditorialiste pas sur
rt au passage je le dis parce que c'est
important
politique pédiatres médecins de tous
bords qui expliquait que les enfants
étaient zero touch et qui n'avait pas de
collier à l'école ce n'était pas vrai un
mensonge ça ça me fout en colère nous
les stylos rouges on a appelé on a
alerté on a deux m'ont dit que des
choses soient faites je rappelle que le
premier mort français c'est un prof
c'est peut-être pas pour rien quand même
eh bien face à cela on a eu du déni des
menteurs d'état un mensonge d'état avec
l'appui de pédiatres médiatique de
médecins médiatique montrent l an
dernier et plus d'un pont se rend compte
que les écoles sont réellement les
premiers clos star écoles et collèges
moi j'ai enseigné au collège les élèves
sont malades on ne fait rien on est
entassé dans les salles je vous invite
monsieur venait dans une salle de classe
passer une journée on verra s'ils posent
en s'empressant de coded voilà ça c'est
la réalité du métier on est environné de
collier dont ne nous protège pas
mais on n'a jamais eu de primes qu ils
viennent on est bien plus à risque par
exemple que d'autres métiers qui ont
touché comme les cheminots j'ai rien
contre eux moi je défends le fait qu'ils
se battent pour leur métier ou leur
salaire nous on n'a rien eu du tout on
est oubliés méprisait on doit se
sacrifier attraper le vide parce que les
parents ne veulent pas garder leurs
gamins une semaine à la maison par
exemple en janvier pour protéger la
collectivité
nous on appelle un sursaut national à ce
niveau là peut-être qu'il faut une
troisième dose je n'en sais rien je ne
suis pas médecin il faudrait déjà que
tous les médecins se mettent d'accord ce
n'est pas gagné mais une troisième dose
efficace une troisième dose efficace
contre mikron c'est pas gagné non plus
pour l'instant je suis désolé je me
renseigne comme tout le monde encore une
fois en tant que citoyen et c'est pas
clair l'information n'est pas claire
il faudrait quelque chose de plus clair
être plus franc de plus honnête
du gouvernement il est avec nous
justement pour réagir un certain nombre
de sujets sur cette question sur cette
question jean paul stade de la
vaccination des enfants âgés de 6 à 10
ans au delà de la question de la
contamination quel serait le bénéfice
médical pour ses enfants qu'elle risque
aussi on parle
d'effets secondaires rares mais qui
existe notamment des réactions aux
cardiaques
oui alors il s'est fait seconder reese
existe vrai c'est tout à fait vrai et ça
a été ça a été vite sans attrait très
rares comme vous venez de le dire donc
toute la question c'est la balance qu'on
est appelé à ce qu'on appelle la balance
bénéfice risque c'est à dire quel est le
bénéfice pour les enfants et pour la
société
dallas vaccination des enfants et quel
est le risque couru par par les enfants
donc la question est très très
honnêtement il n'est pas tranchée moi
j'étais encore en conversation avec mes
collègues pédiatre responsable de la
société sans sa vente de pédiatrie la
question est pas et pas tranché ce qui
est clair c'est que la circulation du
virus est effective et chez les enfants
c'est tout à fait vrai par contre ils ne
développent pas de forme grave et le
service il contamine quelqu'un c'est
quelqu'un qui n'est pas vacciné je le
répète encore une fois là les vacciner
peuvent
dans une certaine mesure et
grossièrement entre 5 et 10% d'entre eux
est à peu près
transmettre du virus mais nous
transmettent à quelqu'un qui est vacciné
et qui est à 100% sans pour se protéger
contre les formes graves finalement ça
n'est pas très important la housse est
important c'est de transmettre le virus
à des personnes qui ne sont pas
immunisés et c'est ça où est la vraie
question donc si on vaccine les enfants
systématiquement c'est pour protéger ces
gens là qui refusent la vaccination
et là on voit très sincèrement en tant
que médecin donc citoyen en tant que ce
que vous voulez c'est quelque chose qui
me choque très profondément et je redis
le vrai problème ce sont les adultes non
vaccinés je vous voyais réagir nicolas
d'hier qu'est ce que vous pensez de ce
que vous venez d'entendre je pense que
c'est absurde c'est contre l'effet des
vaccinés sont contaminés je vous renvoie
monsieur le professeur je crois mais
barkan suis désolé si j'ai quant aux
noms qu'on voit souvent notamment sur
une autre chaîne beaucoup rentrent
m'égare ban voilà qui à lariboisière qui
a reconnu lui même que des vaccinés le
nombre de vaccinés avec un schéma
complet montait à aurea je ne je
n'invente pas ce que dis je je ne suis
pas anti vax jeunes ex je ne pense pas
que des extraterrestres veille vous
injecter un poison ce n'est pas du tout
ce que je vous dis je vous rappelle que
je suis vacciné moi même mais j'ai le
droit d'avoir des doutes j'ai le droit
de voir devant moi que les gens sont
contradictoires ne disent pas toujours
la vérité ou ou la range selon leurs
orientations politiques ou la région
sauront si ce n'est pas normal la
science ça doit être factuel ce n'est
pas idéologique
on en apprend chaque jour jean paul
stahl bon dans votre service à l'hôpital
où vous travaillez ce que vous avez
quelques pourcentages à nous donner sur
le concernant le profil des malades du
kobe dans soit en soins critiques on
évoque généralement un chiffre autour de
75 % des malades de dioko vite placés en
soins critiques qu'ils ne seraient pas
vaccinés les 25% autres seraient des
personnes présentant des comorbidités
alors il ya des comorbidités bien
entendu avec des vaccins qui marche
moins bien chez les personnes
immunodéprimées ça c'est tout à fait
vrai et c'est bien pour ça que je suis
chez eux que l'on a recommandé la
troisième dose en premier et côté qu'il
en faudra chez certains immunodéprimées
pardon un peu plus mais ça c'est quelque
chose qu'on connaît et le très largement
pour les autres vaccins et pas
spécialement pour le vaccin contre
contre lacko vide ça si vous mais si
vous prenez ces personnes qui sont mal
vaccinés sans le vouloir parce que ils
ont effectivement des comorbidités comme
comme vous dites et si vous prenez aussi
les non vaccinés vous obtenez 95% des
explications de
d'hospitalisation c'est clair c'est net
et précis c'est exactement comme ça que
ça se passe dans l'ensemble des services
hospitaliers français mais ça ne veut
pas dire que de façon tout à fait
exceptionnel un vacciner ne pourra pas
présenter une formidable c'est
totalement exceptionnel
on peut imaginer que ça arrivait et on
aura l'occasion de reprendre ce débat
merci à tous les deux d'avoir participé
à cet échange ce soir jean paul stahl a
en fait que cela gosset chf et grenoble
alpes et nicolas glières enseignants
membres des stylos rouges